[Music]  there's 16 at quit school names just  enough for one-way ticket to Paris maybe  I just wanted it really bad then when I  got it too early I didn't had a hold on  to it what do you want him to run the  best restaurant in the world he's sure  he's famous if you're a chef he's like  The Rolling Stones  I don't want my restaurant to be a place  where you come and eat  I don't people to sit at that table be  sick with longing so where you been  Louisiana don't walk slipping snorting  injecting if you tried to start a new  restaurant there were at least a dozen  people who would try to have you killed  the kitchen is the only place I've ever  felt like I really belonged I love every  minute I've got the heat the pressure  the violence what happens if you succeed  fireworks immortality  what happens if you fail  Adam Jones and gold one hoped you were  dead  and then I'm back you look at that all  the time yeah little time so you have  the paps yes yeah look at it yeah yes  yes